cuéntenos cómo podemos definir estos
tres años de buques especialmente el
último con la aplicación del estado de
excepción
en buenas noches muchas gracias por la
invitación
efectivamente podemos definir estos años
de dioses y sombras y con una disyuntiva
muy
fuerte precisamente como lo mencionaba
entre lo que es la figura de bukele a
nivel popular y el fenómeno político se
podría llamar bukele e incluso a nivel
regional y la percepción que muchos
sectores políticos técnicos de sociedad
civil
entre otros y académicos tienen sobre
precisamente el presidente que como ha
mencionado ha venido concentrando el
poder de manera muy rápida en los
últimos en el último año y digamos toma
dos decisiones que
digamos tienen un rasgo se podría decir
autoritario pero sin embargo por el otro
lado ha
tomado medidas que nos nunca se habían
hecho por ejemplo en el país como
subsidios monetarios para la población
entregas de paquetes humanitarios y ha
sabido construir una narrativa y un
discurso y tiene una capacidad
comunicacional tal que efectivamente su
popularidad todavía es muy alta después
de tres años contraria a cualquiera
tendencia de cualquier político en la
región hablemos ahora de su imagen puede
parecer contradictorio que sea
cuestionado por sus acciones y a la vez
se apruebe su gestión porque se da esto
precisamente porque digamos que en una
cosa es digamos el salvadoreño el
lanzador es un país
donde un tercio más o menos de la
población vive en ex en progresa
donde hay digamos comunidades que han
sido marginadas poblaciones marginadas
por diferentes gobiernos a lo largo y
ancho de las últimas décadas y que han
estado muy cansados de los escándalos de
corrupción que han plagado la clase
política en los últimos años y que por
lo tanto han invertido en bukele toda su
esperanza en un cambio
y creen ciegamente se podría decir en lo
que está haciendo el presidente que como
estaba funcionando efectivamente en
ciertos aspectos ha cumplido ha
llegado a estas poblaciones con medidas
que antes nunca se habían tomado por el
otro lado pero hay claramente los que
ven digamos lo que ocurre desde un punto
de vista
y técnicos más digamos éticos y que
queremos llamarlo y de análisis de lo
que está ocurriendo que claramente ven
con preocupación que digamos estas
medidas vengan a costa de una
disminución en la transparencia de una
concentración de poder en una sola
persona y de una actitud digamos
confrontacional con lo que son socios
internacionales e instituciones
financieras ahora todavía hay una
incógnita sobre su eventual reelección
inmediata a pesar de que la constitución
se lo prohíbe el fallo de 2021 de jueces
leales a él abrieron la posibilidad de
un nuevo mandato que significaría que
aplicará para un nuevo período
pues no sería desafortunadamente ni el
primero ni el último en la región
centroamericana y más allá que digamos
apunta a una reelección a pesar de que
sea claramente
prohibida por la constitución ha
ocurrido en nicaragua ha ocurrido en
honduras y bueno es posible que vuelva a
ocurrir en otros lugares yo creo que los
costos
de políticos sean muy bajos a nivel
interno claramente esto podría ser mal
visto a nivel internacional pero en el
momento en que la sala de lo
constitucional
claramente más afín al gobierno en este
momento
defina efectivamente puede correr el
presidente corriente si lo quiere pues
está en su potestad